all right uh welcome everybody so my man
is epic on Michael and I believe that
everybody has one word that defines them
and they should use that one word to the
movement tough other people at will the
business and so every month I check in
with some of my students and today I've
got rich with me this is our third
session I think his he's a photographer
videographer has done a lot of great
work with some famous people and his one
word is inspired and he wants people to
to be inspired so rich welcome aboard
man thank you nice to be back level
three mr. level three now three yeah
what did I do to accomplish that just a
couple more likes ah youtube you're
getting more YouTube views ah nice
you're in your car where are you there
yeah i'm in my cards it's one of those
days where i'm on the road all day so i
can't prepare this time very cool okay
so it's been going on ah you know what
not a whole heck of a lot just kind of
keeping the same thing going the
consistency just been working on
creating some more inspiring images and
spokes working on some new videos and
that's it for now okay so it is it a
regular schedule we last time we talked
we had the um yeah monday was your cough
wednesday was a video and friday famous
quote yeah you got it i might have to
make monday themes quotes to all i'll be
running out of mine sooner than later
yeah you haven't heard that you are you
know died yeah yeah i see another month
going but we'll see what happens beyond
that but I've got a ton of great quotes
that I love ah that you know I think
would be great and also coming up with
images as well as interesting i gotta
because i'm trying to put an image that
would make sense to the quote
yeah and if it doesn't I'll just put one
of my landscape photos yeah because that
kind of goes with whatever but there's
some quotes that either have a lot of
texts that overpowers damage so I'm just
going to figure out a design to do it do
it within for a bunch of the quotes I
might have to just kind of get inspired
and go out and take some new photos and
cystic lesion is I'm gonna run out of
photos for this right because good I'm
feeling I'm feeling the new photos the
new inspire photos that's right um so
I've been sharing your stuff the ones
that I like I've been sharing and they
get together they get about an average
response on my slicker um in terms of
tweets and likes and all that I'm
wondering though like are you really
keep you'll each post in your gut like
mmm yeah that's what I'm talking about
when you post them no that's interesting
uh I'll have to have to kind of revisit
and I think what's a bunch of them I do
there's probably few of them that I just
really like is they make me think yeah
but there's probably less of them that
are just like you feel them in the gut
are you implying go for the gut yeah
well you know what I'm just wondering if
you know we got this schedule and that's
great and the consistency is great and
I'm I'm just wondering if some of them
that are going up are you know some
things that are good that you think
you're good and use like okay I gotta
get something up today's I'm gonna post
this but aren't like mmm yeah baby I'm
feeling this one you get the difference
yeah
let me say like for me some of them I
look at and I get right away and I love
them and I want to share them and others
i look at and and okay maybe they make
me things but it's not doesn't hit me as
hard and maybe that's just me that's
cool like I'm not gonna with different
people that's fine i'm not going to
relate to everything exactly you have
but i'm just one of if you're getting
the same thing rather if you're posting
it because you know you gotta hit the
schedule or if you're really actually
feeling like i'm proud that i put that
up I'm proud of created this I'm resting
my hat to say Richard made this this is
amazing you get that it suck you put
enough yeah here yeah I know if I put
stuff to that test then it'll definitely
be lesser in quantity that's for sure
yeah sure now I have to really kind of
sit back with it and try to kind of look
at it feel it out and now that we have
this conversation I'll do that and I'll
see what really stands out because I'm
just about put some new what new ones
together cuz you just butt out of all
the ones i had I'm just creating new
ones now so I could do that now and
though what do you suggest to do like if
there's only a handful let's say that
I'm really in love with or really fail
feel but I need more content what do i
do at that point um you gotta look
deeper into your even your day-to-day
life like this is your word this is what
you are all about there's got to be
things that come up if it if it's
personally your family or meeting to
have with people or you consume
something and if it's a code that you
see somewhere or video to watch
somewhere and I'm just remembering to
save it to use for this purpose so here
like I call into this
challenged myself to UM even today so
today I'm just before this call I was
eating my my lunch I had a tuna steak
and some green beans and I was watching
some YouTube videos and I watched an
interview with Kanye West and nelson
mandela who was on the oprah winfrey
show and I was watching I was like wow
that's some good stuff and then I
skipped and went on to other stuff never
let you know what like there are some
moments in both of those videos that
really stuck with me that I need to
share and had to go back to those videos
again and pull out the clips so that i
could post it to my audience as well
because i really loved it it's stuck
with me here and it makes sense that I
gotta now share with the audience to as
part of the movement so it's just being
aware of your environment your
surroundings and things that in your
day-to-day life inspire you if you if
you're reading or you're watching
something and remembering that hey I
could use this in my content yeah right
like I do you watch youtube videos are
you reading are you what do you what are
you doing what are you doing like how do
you get inspired day to day no I don't
schedule it and then like you do uh I
really need to I want to kind of get a
handle on how to kind of schedule that
in and just kind of like what's your
process how do you schedule that Excel
go with through days forgetting about it
i'll listen to my audios or have a books
that i read but online i don't do it so
much online well whatever if its books
there's got to be some great quotes in
there or it's a passage that makes you
think yeah no I mean you're reading
books Yeah right you're listening to
audio maybe you're in the car maybe it
was just on before you know you got on
this call with me there's got to be
something that people are saying on
there even if it's a song right like I
don't know what you're listening to
keeping audiobook or or you know whoever
comes on your listing your blacks in
some nine inch nails and something comes
on there and like a lyric six with you
go
that's all content right like anything
that gets you to feel inspired could
help other people as well doesn't have
to be online doesn't have to be a hope
you see online or video that you watch
online yeah it's just for a meta brain
trying to pull that out and and think of
it not just you but like I can use this
to help inspire the people as well okay
i was watching um Neil Dragons Den even
walk Dragon's Den yeah okay so dragon
stand there was a deal that Arlene made
with this 82 year old entrepreneur and
this was his dream and and you know a
couple years later she got his product
into home depot and she surprised him
and bottom there and he sees his you
know finally his product was in the
shelf and he's crime and his family's
crying and Arlene is crying and I'm
watching it and I'm crying I'm crying
watching this and then after the show
ended like wow that was a really
emotional moment and I should share that
with my audience too and so I went to
find the clip on YouTube and and I did a
quick intro like I was on for maybe 20
seconds as a hey here's why I love this
video and then showed the clip which is
maybe four minutes long and and put that
up and that video has it's only been up
for a couple days and it's that you know
I don't know 60 comments or something
that's fun crazy but because that meant
something to me right and there was
something that I was already doing like
I'm already watching this stuff in my
daily I don't schedule dragons den time
in but there are moments of believe
throughout my daily life and their
moments have inspired throw your daily
life you just have to pay attention to
them and thinking this could be a cool
moment that I could use to help inspire
other people right even now like you're
driving you can have your camera with
you at all times you see something a
nice potential picture right like snap
it with people whatever you're doing
there is opportunity inspiring picture
all the time this is being aware of it
make it a task you're gonna kind of bomb
what you might are completing right like
right here yeah you got a super busy day
I gotta spend an hour looking for some
stupid online quotes and watching video
or write it becomes this thing that you
get pissed off at work for finding just
finding things in your daily life if
you're reading books there's gonna be
tons of stuff you can pull out hmm let
how are you yeah I know it does doesn't
yeah I I might get stuck again with the
how you know okay so I read something
good in a book okay i can write it out
kind of the way I get it from the book
now now I gotta find a picture to shoot
it or I could just kind of create a
quote with nothing else right I can do
that too yeah it's a ruthless don't I
you make the rules right I forget that
every once in a while I get okay it's
got a big this way cuz that's what I did
before but I can kind of swing it can't
I yeah i mean i love your your logo at
the bottom right inspire and yeah things
that inspire that's awesome you can put
down on a black background with the
quote with beautiful typography that's
the longest of quote means something to
you right like the quote hits you in the
gut then it's worth sharing like the
visuals are great if you can add on top
of it but don't let that hold you back
from not not sharing it so yeah Jason's
writing in here he said I cried to
watching that video that I put up and he
asked were you proud of your lemon
deodorant vlog hahahaha proud enough to
take it off for now until I'm ready to
flesh it out make it something more fun
now we want to see that post rich we
want to see that yeah I know I've got a
whole bunch of those I'm just gonna step
by step up and step by step you know
we'll take one car
crunch off at a time later I'll be
running yeah I've got a bunch of those
ideas and I've actually even started
with some interviews with some of those
people that have inspired me and taught
me stuff before that are totally
unrelated to photography or or film or
anything like that it just like the
lemon blog right or there is a guy that
kind of taught me something that you can
easily overlooked but it's how to
breathe or how to move but how to do it
and a really chilled out when harmonious
waiting for the body tight it's kind of
weird to explain in words you kind of
gotta just see it in field but so I've
already interviewed him just about his
his concepts and his ideas I've got
stuff ready in the background it's just
a matter of me putting it together
mm-hmm you know what's gonna walk people
in is your curiosity and interest in the
subject yeah so like why do you care
about this guidance teaching you how to
breathe or whatever it is right or not
it accepts tires like why do you care so
your interest in your career it comes
out a little bit in the questions
already right and I think the most
recent one you're now on camera you're
not on camera but your voice is on
camera you hear what the other right and
that tree asti is what brings people in
so I'd even start with and you know
we're now taking off another crutch but
I think what's starting with a quick 30
second to one minute intro before you
get to the guy of you on camera saying
why you're interested in this guy had a
feeling you're gonna say that ah right I
could sense it before you said it's like
I already heard this conversation in my
head just 30 seconds before you said it
up it's happening it's happening it
would be really powerful right like and
it's not about you this is to help guide
your audience right and it should like
okay who is this guy and it helps string
if you look at the people
you're interviewing it may not make any
sense like you were talking with success
Diaries now you're talking about you
lame like well how is this connected
doesn't make any sense you are the bread
across everything and you're interesting
curiosity so if you come on and say you
know it's really interesting interesting
to talk to this guy because XYZ and
share like a quick personal bit of
information that would really bring me
in a now wanna watch it right like rich
says that I'm to watched it I want to
watch the description there yeah weeks
ago now we're into the Torah sorry so
good I kind of walked over you what you
say Jason is saying that you sound way
more excited about this stuff how is how
high in fact the more excited about this
than what I don't know maybe the
pictures Oh like you gotta follow your
passion are the videos coming up every
um everyone today I did there is didn't
I put one out yesterday they did not you
know what I did it this time because I
was on the road again I put it out with
my phone because it was already out I
just need to put the share the link
maybe something wrong you didn't see you
anything yesterday um you know I think I
did your we gotta fix your your posting
cuz when it comes out the first one so
it was the guy who stood it was the
trainer guy right the yeah right and it
was shamma if you want what I have you
have to do what I to do because it right
okay uh what's wrong with it in history
cuz i put i put the link in and in
automatically pops up a picture and the
title yeah we've got to fix it cuz i
posted twice and the first is with the
purse is just a picture oh right and
it's the quote which is it like it's a
great quote but then it's just a picture
that the court is not on the picture and
then in close the video right afterwards
there's two different messages so
as someone who follows you on twitter is
very confusing yeah oh you've got to
think that you've got to fix that
technology man what's a new post um that
was meant to be just be a video post
right not the picture yeah yeah it was
meant to be a video post you know what I
might have because what I've done now is
I've turned off the the auto posting for
the videos okay until I you know I can
do the scheduled post so I turned that
off I must have forgot this one because
what I ended up doing is I ended up
copying the link or sharing it through
my YouTube page i went to the YouTube
page and share it using the share link
okay so but I might have done it a
little too late after the first one was
already posted but will sadly picture
Dick the first ones a picture the a
person was the automatic one so that was
a bad one okay did this second what was
the second one good second one's better
yeah was better but still not good um
another second is the videos that was
okay so that was fun okay can you in
that configure that up so so you know
going forward now I mean I'll keep an
eye on to what I want to make sure that
you're like the challenges you're not
creating a great experience or someone
who's following you on Twitter right huh
if you want it to be a good experience
for people so they can say hey you
should follow this guy because he had
awesome stop right yeah um so so going
forward what's our schedule gonna look
like what's our schedules I don't know
you tell me what I need some direction
what do I need to do well I like the
video every Wednesday that's great yeah
so there's the monday wednesday friday
the quote video quote yeah and on the
upcoming videos i'm gonna figure out
putting an intro by me on it I'm liking
that and what else for these years whoa
so are you gonna keep the mud
for the quotes am I gonna keep what my
my yeah yeah I will I'm gonna open up my
mind the concept of finding inspire
everywhere yes it exists everywhere just
you know some things I still have any
ambitions about sharing you know I think
there's a lot of awesome stuff that my
little boyston all the time it's like a
it's a gong show with them is always
something funny happening something
that's really you know inspiring or cool
or just fun that I think could be
worthwhile but not sure should we go
there also or um you can try I mean it's
got to be again something that you feel
proud of like you read that and it gets
you with inspired right and it should
inspire other people as well if you had
a picture of your son on one of the
quotes and not be well I mean people
didn't know that it was your son and
I'll share stuff of like Hayden singing
let it go from frozen or whatever and
that's up is more kind of for the
hardcore audience you know the commune's
because they want a little you know peek
into your life and that's fine but
like--imagine to somebody you could I
think it'd be telling your kids story on
the position of somebody who doesn't
know you so like what did he do that is
so inspiring that everybody can benefit
from it cuz right now you know you don't
have a core audience yet they were you
know we're starting to build that up um
well here's good example okay here's a
story that that maybe you can find a way
to tell it with your kids I was
snowboarding one day and I was on the
ski lift and I saw a girl goin down the
hills and the whole time I was there she
kept trying to do jumps like go down and
then jump and then go down and then jump
in the good and she felt like every time
she fell she fell she fell and I've been
sitting there thinking and like I hope I
want her to make it like every time I'm
on the lip I see her just falling like I
hope she makes it i hope you and then
finally she made it her like she
made it and then she fell again whatever
and and slowly she got better and better
i met her and she started making it more
and then I was on the hill and I thought
you know what I want to try doing jumps
I've never I got I got scared like oh I
don't want to do jumps here you know
people are gonna watch me I'm gonna fall
I'm gonna look I'm going to embarrass
like I shouldn't do it and then I
remembered that hey you know I was up on
the lift cheering that person on not
laughing at them falling I wanted her to
succeed and and you know the other
people they won't be laughing at me
falling you know if anything you want me
to to hit it so I shouldn't be as
embarrassed about it so that's like
that's a true story that's what happens
we saw I tried to jump on I fell lots of
times and then actually I hit it but a
story like that like you don't need to
know me you don't need to know much
about it to understand it and to relate
that to your life so you know what can
you tell about your kids if you're
comfortable like if you're not
comfortable due to the kids whatever
it's got but again like tell me
something that can inspire me to make a
change in my life so if it's your kids
it's great give me it from the point of
view like I don't know who your kids are
and by reading this story or by looking
at this picture watching this video I'm
inspired to make a positive change in my
life stop Charlie well I'm thinking even
as a comedic break and sometimes they'll
they'll be just something hilarious that
you can catch on video or oreo something
that can happen or they say or so but
i'll see i'll keep my uh my eyes and
ears open for this stuff and see if I
feel it if I feel it in my gut i'll i'll
give you the fur the fruit dibs i think
alright cool i'm feeling that um that's
good and and for all the social media
posts to write the monday wednesday
friday so she the monday-friday those
pictures yeah you want to make sure that
each one you put up you feel strongly
about and if you don't then maybe
only once a week like I'd rather have
you do once a week and it's awesome than
twice a week and you're just trying to
put something out ah ok all right those
that it is that money along I love some
of those videos that you put out to just
oh yeah that that is your homework man
that is some serious on that and you
getting on camera in front of your next
video yeah yeah that's the homework we
have even gone to tell in riches story
yet we'll get there at some point my
story oh this will be interesting
founding story like to hear my schooling
your founding critical this is critical
anyway um yeah just a quick note i love
the beauties that you're putting up you
had the the will smith on like I will
die a treadmill and the ones um
obviously schedule those out but but it
looks great I think it's great for the
audience and people watch that it'll
help you know when they watch one to
watch another to watch you know they'll
start to subscribe to your channel so
well done right keep it up oh thank you
evan i'm right on watching yeah we're
getting getting some good feedback some
people just saying hello and watching a
bad idea saying hello and fillies decent
and few others so fun times anyway have
a great month rich thank you yes indeed
yeah they care have a great one yes